Y esta es una victoria para Twitter
justo antes del juicio en el que la
compañía pidió obligar al Magnate a
completar la transacción
de acuerdo Ángela al final creo que más
que se jugó una carta y la junta de
Twitter se jugó el blog y dijo Ok si
queremos ir al juicio bueno
nuestras cartas sino también las suyas y
creo que a menos de una semana los
abogados debemos creyeron ella sabe que
creo que nos va a tocar Si no queremos
seguir teniendo que contar todo lo que
no hemos contado nos va a tocar proceder
con la transacción bueno Y entonces En
qué quedaron estas largas disputas que
iniciaron por las cuentas Bots que según
most no fueron debidamente informadas
que Twitter había dicho inicialmente que
estaban en un 5% Pero serían muchas más
Sí desde un comienzo y creo que lo
habíamos hablado con algunos de tus
compañeros esto parecía ser una
estrategia para negociar Y tratar de
bajar un poco el precio que
originalmente se había ofrecido por la
por la compañía al final eso eso se
guarda en un cajón y sencillamente la
transacción va a pasar como se había
propuesto en un comienzo Y entonces ya
no irían a juicio dentro de un par de
semanas seguramente la transacción tiene
que ser completada ya fue aprobada por
los accionistas y tiene que ser
completada antes de la fecha de inicio
ese 17 de octubre del juicio para que no
se dé sino que sencillamente se haga el
traspaso de las acciones ahí los demás
bueno Y este pleito entre tanto ha
lastimado bastante las fluctuaciones de
la compañía que recibirá el un mosque
con la compra de Twitter y cómo
afectaría su privatización
si yo creo que hay dos factores
importantes el primero es que el hecho
de estar cotizando en la bolsa obliga a
la compañía a andar mostrando unos
números trimestre que no son los mejores
Mientras que al ser una compañía privada
pues la compañía puede tomar decisiones
de más largo plazo sin que se vea
afectado en el corto plazo el precio de
la acción y el segundo creo yo y es algo
de lo que vimos en los en los mails
intercambiados por mosc con el ex
fundador o con el fundador con Jack
dorsey un poco tratar de devolverle la
independencia a la compañía y no
depender tanto el tema de publicidad
para tratar de que la compañía vuelva a
crecer y encuentre un modelo de negocio
que sea sostenible en el largo plazo
Pues bien y finalmente qué tanto tenía
que perder el modo que si se iban a
juicio en un par de semanas para decidir
hacer este reversazo después de tantos
meses de conflicto con Twitter
la jurisprudencia digamos nunca ha sido
favorable por lo menos en este tipo de
casos con respecto a inversionistas que
luego deciden echarse para atrás en un
proceso como este históricamente los
jueces en donde en un proceso como esto
generalmente han favorecido a las
compañías que serán adquiridas Entonces
yo creo que al final del día nos dijo
Mira al final me va a tocar comprarla me
va a tocar hacer un disclosu de una
cantidad de información que no quiero
hacer sabe que paguemos lo que tenemos
que pagar y salgamos de esto